vous êtes responsable des collections du
musée franck perrais de saint-pierre le
mémorial de la catastrophe de 1902 alors
à l'occasion de la 120ème annie de la
commémoration de la catastrophe vous
organisez une exposition intitulée le
souffle de saint-pierre mémoire
incandescente il s'agit d'une exposition
sonore expliquez nous oui tout à fait
c'est une exposition qui a été donc
organisé par le mémorial de la
catastrophe et on a missionné
l'artiste sonore fabienne pélage pour
s'attacher donc à réaliser cette
exposition qui est donc une exposition
sonore en deux parties elle a réalisé
une douzaine de capsules sonores qui
sont répartis sur le territoire de saint
pierre donc qui incite le visiteur à
venir découvrir la ville à travers ses
capsules et ses capsules sont le
résultat de témoignages d'héritier de la
catastrophe donc ce sont
des témoignages qui sont le fruit
souvent de mémoire orale d'accord comme
ont été sélectionnés ces témoignages
alors ces témoignages sont
issus de personnes qui se sont
manifestées auprès du mémorial à la
suite du refus de la refonte du musée en
2019 des personnes se sont rapprochés de
notre institution pour donner des objets
ou pour témoigner ou pour apporter des
archives montrent bien la deuxième
partie la deuxième partie est en cours
de réalisation
elle va se se caractériser par donc la
formation d'une quinzaine de podcasts
donc toujours par fabienne pélage qui
attend que messieurs et mesdames les
auditeurs veuille bien leur appelé
appelé à un numéro pour témoigner on est
dans la tente de thé d'autres
témoignages pour constituer ses podcasts
plus rapidement donné le numéro vous la
tête
c'est donc
le 05 96 10 64 83 et ce sont des
podcasts qui seront réalisés tout au
long de l'année de cette commémoration
donc là ce sont des témoignages aussi
qui seront recueillies voilà tout à fait
si on recueille les témoignages après il
ya une création artistique autour de ces
témoignages qu'est ce que je voulais
dire
les comment se fait le choix des lieux
où sont disposées les les podcasts vous
avez les deux premiers postes à ce
podcast ordre voilà alors les douze
capsules sonore ce sont des petites
capsules d'une minute un peu près qui
qui sont assez dynamique assez gai qui
invite à découvrir la ville qui font
référence à des lieux souvent le lieu où
a été positionné la capsule donc cette
capsule est tout un système de qr codes
qu'on scan avec le portable et qui donne
accès gratuitement à ces capsules
d'accord ce sont des bandes comment les
européens ces capsules c'est ses
capsules enfin cesser qr codes ont été
mis sur des panneaux déjà existants dans
saint pierre s'il s'agit de quoi de
chemin initiatique
qu'on va qu'on va suivre au fur au fur
et à mesure c'est une expérience chacun
vivra comme il le veut mais en tout cas
c'est une expérience dynamique et
vivante qu'on invite à aller essayer il
bien sûr il ya un lien entre
l'exposition permanente au musée franck
perrais et
oui les différentes capsules cetc oui
c'est ça complète en fait la mémoire est
une thématique un sujet important pour
memorial tout autant que les objets
parce que tous les deux la mémoire et
les objets témoignent de cette histoire
d'accord il faut se rendre au musée
d'abord et ensuite faire le con procède
comme en
librairie thiers de personnes
d'expérience mais on recommande bien sûr
visiter le musée alors ce ce musée
justement vous avez aujourd'hui combien
de pièces on a un peuple un peu plus à
peu plus un parlons un peu plus de 400
pièces dans la collection qui est classé
20 qui bénéficient de l'appellation
musée de france mais à l'heure actuelle
on a à peu près deux tiers de la
collection qui ce qui est exposé dans le
musée d'accord c'est ce que je vais vous
poser comme question est-ce que tout est
exposé il ya des dix archives qu'est-ce
que vous avez choisi d'exposer
exactement au moment donc de la refonte
du musée en 2019 il a été choisi par
l'équipe scientifique de ne pas tout
exposé de faire une sélection précise
donc il ya un gros travail autour des
collections un travail de nettoyage de
présentation et aussi de documentation
s'agit d'une collection qui est classé
musée de france donc c'est une
collection qui est considéré comme
trésor national une collection très
importante le musée ne peut pas exister
sans cette collection mais cette
collection mérite encore d'être
documenté elle est très très peu
documentée en sait peu de choses elle a
été constituée par le créateur de ce
musée qui saperait pelle franck halvor
de perec étaient américains et qui est
venu en martinique en 1929 dans un
contexte particulier de sursaut de la
montagne pelée et il a décidé de créer
ce musée en recueillant les objets issus
des ruines de saint-pierre et donc on a
sélectionné les objets les plus
marquants pour re compte refaire ce
musée si on devait donner à nos
auditeurs et même aux touristes de
passage un exemple des objets à voir et
à visiter ce serait crois qu'elle a les
deux objets qui retiennent l'attention
qui pourrait retenir l'attention deux
objets alors bien sûr
la cloche de saint-etienne de l'église
de saint-etienne du centre qui est
l'objet phare de la collection c'est une
cloche qui fait plus d'une tonne qui a
été déformé littéralement fondu par l'
incendie consécutif de la nuée ardente
elle a été fondue déformés et cassé et
ça c'est vraiment l'objet phare on peut
la retrouver dans le mémorial qui est le
coeur du musée actuel est le deuxième
objet qui est un petit peu plus
ordinaire qui paye pas de mine mais
quand on le regarde de près c'est un
vase en cristal de baccarat qui était à
l'origine transparent et qui est devenu
donc qui est complètement fondu qu'est
ce qui s'est transformée et qui est
devenu noir parce que la sens et est
rentré dans le dans le cristal vous avez
suivi vous avez participé à une
formation il y a quelques semaines une
formation musée y risques naturels
majeurs initiée par la ctm et le conseil
international des musées comment on
était grand ce n'était guère ce
paramètre de risque majeur dans la
conception et de musées dans
l'exposition des oeuvres
c'est une bonne question dès le départ
quand il a été question de refaire le
musée on a pris en compte la
vulnérabilité du territoire de saint
pierre dans la présentation des
collections à savoir qu'on a posés on à
souk les chacun des objets sur avec un
socle particulier donc il ya une équipe
de soccer qui est venu de france
hexagonale ici qu'à passer deux semaines
à souk l'es11 chaque objet de manière à
ce qu'ils puissent
résister aux secousses sismiques donc
des socles sous des coussins qui vibre
une envie bras sion alors comment ce
sont donc des socles ajusté avec un
système d'aimants donc on dirait que les
yeux les objets sont en suspension dans
les vitrines et je vous invite à venir
voir parce que c'est vraiment
spectaculaire au niveau de la technicité
vous avez aussi des vitrines anti
vibrations tout à fait les vitrine
tablettes sont avec des supports en
tiges et l'oratoire d'accord et quand on
travaille au pied de la montagne on a un
regard particulier sur cette montagne ou
bien on voit plus la montagne du tout
bien il ya une appréhension ce je pense
que ça dépend de tout un chacun du
ressenti de chacun moi je sais que je ne
la vois plus si ce n'est par son
caractère
majestueux mais je pense qu'il faut
apprendre à vivre avec et surtout faire
face aux risques
avec lucidité c'est ce que nous a appris
cette formation qui était donc a été
menée par par l'icom et part
donc par le conseil des musées
internationaux et par la maque donc
l'association des musées de la caraïbe
en partenariat avec la 7ème bien sûr et
ce qui nous apprennent dans cette
formation c'est à gérer le risque et à
gérer le risque en créant des outils qui
nous aident à gérer ce risque des plans
de sauvegarde des plans sauvegarde tout
à fait alors plan de sauvegarde ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il faut
hiérarchiser les oeuvres prioriser les
oeuvres tout à fait oui vous avez bien
compris je mens cela par ma vision c'est
elle c'est l'aspect le plus compliqué
pour un responsable de collection de
hiérarchiser
les collections savoir quel objet une
somme en priorité en cas de dalea en cas
de problème et c'est très très complexe
parce que des objets qui peuvent
paraître ordinaires ont toute leur
importance et des objets qui parle qui
peuvent paraître primordial primordiaux
pardon ben on ne peut pas les déplacer
comme la cloche bien clos ce qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec l'association
lalla sur place ou pas voilà c'est là
qu'elle a déjà résisté une première fois
voilà donc vous avez déjà répondu c'est
que on va après on va prioriser et
sélectionner les objets les plus
vulnérables les plus fragiles et les
plus plus sensibles madame marie a dit
ça y est je vous remercie ne bougeait
pas dans quelques minutes vous aurez
droit aux questions des auditeurs germi
ont des questions nombreuses aux
standards 05 96 63 23 23 ans rappellera
également le numéro pour les témoignages
on va retrouver la rédaction de francs